The true power of docker is the ability
to not only build images, but
share them with others.
To do that we'll need to host our images
on a remote container image registry
such as the Docker Hub.
Review the output of
the docker images command and
notice the name of our
monolith container.
By default all doc images
go to the Docker Hub
which assume that you
own that repository.
So what we're going to do is use our own
name space which is our Docker username.
So what we'll have to do is add
our user name to our Docker image
using the Docker tag command command.
>From the help output,
you can see that we take an existing
image tag combination and
we add a user name and a repository.
The repository would be important if we
were pushed into a different repository
other than the in the default
docker hub like GCR or QUAY.IO.
But since we're not,
we'll just add a username.
Let's add the username using
the docker tag command.
Now if we use the Docker image command,
you can see we have our tag.
>From this output you can see that
the Kelsey Hightower Monolith image name
has the same image ID
as a monolith image.
Now we are ready to push our current
tenor image to the docker hub.
Used the Docker push command to push
our image up to the Docker hub.
So that didn't work.
That's because we need to log in
before we can push to the registry.
We can use the docker
login command to do that.
Now let's try to push
our Docker image again.
It worked this time, and
now we have a hosted image
that we can share with others.